Good morning everyone.
We are finally there.
We're finally at the coliseum,
the very icon of Rome.
And because I think of the coliseum is a very icon of Rome.
I've called today's lecture,
the creation of an icon,
the Coliseum and contemporary architecture in Rome.
But before we discuss the coliseum,
I want to say a few words,
a few more words about neuro,
the last of the Julio,
Claudia and emperors.
And I show you a portrait of Nero here.
Ensconced in his dome is our area with the fourth style wall of fabulous behind
him.
And I wanted to just say [inaudible] and bring your attention to the fact that
it really is quite amazing that we have the names of so many of Nero's artists
and architects and that can only attest to the fact that he must have gathered
around him truly the greatest artists of the day,
artists whose accomplishments were so suburb,
uh,
that their names have been recorded for posterity at a time when very few
artists and architects names are recorded.
And I just want to remind you of that group.
Uh,
think of course of the painter of Nero,
the man who was responsible for painting the third style walls of Nero's Domus
area,
fabulous himself.
Uh,
and who also appears to have been the innovator of the fourth style of Roman
wall painting.
There was also Xena Doris,
who was the most famous bronze caster of his day,
a Greek artist of great renown whom neuro hired to make his colossal statue,
the colossal statue,
125 feet tall out of bronze that depicted neuro in the guise of the sun,
God,
Saul,
and a statue that was referred to as the colossus.
And lastly,
but not least,
by any stretch of the imagination with the two architects of Nero Severus and
Keller Roman architects,
we believe Severus Keller,
who were responsible for the Domus aurea itself for all the architectural
innovations and experimentations at the dome,
Miss Our area.
Uh,
and it was they who we believe we're the creators of the remarkable octagonal
room.
As I mentioned last time,
probably the most extraordinary room we've seen thus far this semester,
and one that's going to have lasting impact on later Roman buildings.
And complexes.
So the octagonal room.
And also I mentioned to you other things in the villa,
including a banqueting hall with a revolving ceilings.
So these men,
also great architectural innovators.
So when Nero is forced to commit suicide in 68,
we have to ask ourselves what happened to those artists?
What happened to those innovations after the day after Nero was discredited?
And I mentioned also last time that when Nero was,
was committed suicide,
when he was discredited,
he received an official dom,
not too Memoria I from the Senate,
uh,
damnation of his memory,
which meant that his portraits,
uh,
could not,
could be.
And we're encouraged to be destroyed.
And the same with his buildings.
So what is going to happen to the evolution of Roman architecture when one of
its greatest patrons,
someone who encouraged the greatest architects and artists of the day,
uh,
when he and his memory are annihilated and his buildings are destroyed,
what is going to happen to architectural innovation?
That's the main question we need to ask ourselves today as we look at the
buildings that were commissioned by his successors,
by members of the Flavian Dynasty.
Vespasian Titus and ultimately demission.
We'll talk about Vespasian today,
a bit on Titus and then more on Titus and demission on Tuesday.
What happens to these innovations,
uh,
when they begin to take over and when they begin to commission buildings and
we're going to see it's mixed,
we're going to see a certain move back toward a conservative,
uh,
vision.
Uh,
but we're also going to see that narrows innovations live on.
And that's the most exciting piece of,
of this particular Flavian puzzle as we shall see.
So we see again,
neuro here.
Uh,
and when Nero,
when Nero died in 68,
a d,
uh,
what happened was not only that he received a dumb not to your Memoria,
but there were no other Julio.
Claudius is to succeed.
Him and Rome and the empire were plunged once again into a very serious civil
war,
a civil war that was as,
uh,
as profound,
profoundly,
profoundly troubling as the civil war that had followed Caesar's death.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Caesar's death is Caesar's death as you know,
in 44 BC.
And what emerged after the civil war or during the civil war was a one of the
most complicated,
uh,
and difficult years in Rome's history.
The year 68 to 69 during which Rome had four emperors,
not coal emperors as Rome to have much later in its history,
but competing emperors in very quick succession,
some of them holding onto power for only a few months.
These men were a ball ba Gal ba,
whose portrait you see on a coin in the upper left,
a bell boy who becomes emperor right after Nero's death.
And you can see him in a no nonsense,
uh,
realistic portrait on that coin in the upper left.
He is succeeded very soon after by a man by the name of Ortho,
You see him on the gold coin on the right Ortho who saw Nero as a soul mate and
had himself rendered very much with the neurosurgeon hairstyle as you can see.
And then third,
uh,
a man by the name of the telly is v I,
t,
e,
l,
I,
U s,
but Tullius who seems to have had more chins than any other and for in the
history of Rome,
as you can see him,
this wonderful portrait now in Copenhagen.
And then ultimately Vespasian ves,
p a,
s I a n Vespasian,
uh,
who was the only one of these four who was able to hold onto power long enough
to create a new dynasty,
a new dynasty that he called after his family name,
Flavio.
This was his family name,
the so called Flavian Dynasty.
And the fortune was on his side because he had two sons to succeed him,
Titus and demission.
Uh,
and because he had two sons to succeed him,
he was able to,
uh,
create a,
a quite successful dynasty as we shall see,
that had a lasting power.
So this is our second main imperial dynasty,
the Flavian Dynasty as opposed to the Augustan and Julio,
Claudia Dynasty.
Now Vespasian came to power in a civil war and like Augustus before him.
He recognized that although coming to power in the civil war could give you the
authority that you needed to govern.
It didn't give you the legitimacy.
It was very important in the eyes of the Romans to have had an important foreign
victory to give your dynasty legitimacy.
Augustus came to power after his civil war with Marc Antony.
Uh,
but he looked to his victory over the Parthians in the eastern part of the
Empire to give his reign legitimacy.
Vespasian does the same thing.
He comes to power and the civil war,
he beats back other Romans.
So he has to look elsewhere for legitimacy.
And he also looks east.
Uh,
he looks specifically to Judea,
a antisense his son in his son Titus in a to do war against Jerusalem.
And Titus was victorious in the early Seventies.
Aidy in this very important Jewish war that I'll have more to say about later
today.
And also,
uh,
especially on Tuesday.
So the space and also a con is a,
is a,
with his son,
Titus is a victor and a foreign war.
And that becomes the basis of their right to rule.
And we'll see references to those Jewish wars in their art.
Even in our conversation today.
I also want to say with regard to Vespasian,
not only was he a,
uh,
a great military strategist,
but he also seems to have been an extremely shrewd politician.
Someone who recognized that you could use architecture in the service of
ideology.
And that's in fact what we're going to see him doing today.
And he starts this from the very beginning of his reign.
I go back here too,
and we'll look at it a number of times a day.
It really is going to loom large in our,
in,
in today's discussion,
the site plan of Nero's don't miss our area that we looked at last time.
And you'll remember the location of the bold and house of Neuro up,
uh,
on the Espolon Hill.
The only part of it that's still survives the so called eschalon wing,
which you can see there and hear the great artificial lake,
uh,
the colossus buys and Doris located over there.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and you can see the way those are deployed,
in that 300 to 350,
uh,
area area,
that acres of area that,
uh,
that,
Nero had his architects build up.
Claudius,
excuse me,
Vespasian as he thinks about how to move forward with architecture and to begin
to commission buildings.
The first thing that strikes him very wisely is he does not want to associate
himself with Nero.
In fact,
he wants to disassociate himself with Nero who is now been damned,
but he looks back at the Julio Claudius and he recognizes that there is some
merit in linking himself with them.
Uh,
and quite specifically with Claudius,
who was the,
it was the best after,
in addition to Augustus was the best of the more recent lot.
And Claudius was made into a god at his death.
So he looks to Claudius and he notices the fact that there is a temple of
Claudius that was begun on this very property by Claudia says wife.
Uh,
his last wife Ag.
We're Pina.
The younger,
the woman with the poison mushrooms ag repeating to the younger who also you'll
recall was the mother of neuro and Agra Pina.
The younger had begun after Claudius is death and divinization a temple in honor
of Claudius Nero who had no,
no particular affection for his mother.
And his,
you'll remember had her murdered,
uh,
decided that he didn't want any part of her building project either and,
and put a stop to it,
especially when he decided that he had other plans for this particular area of
Rome.
Uh,
namely to build his pleasure palace.
So neuro stops construction.
He doesn't destroy the building,
but he stopped construction on it and just leaves it as it is.
The light bulb goes on for Vespasian investigation says to himself,
the best way that I can use architecture to make a connection to make a link
between myself and the Julio,
Claudia Ans especially Claudius,
is to finish the temple of Claudius.
That Agora peanut began.
And that's exactly what he sets out to do.
And he does this at the very beginning of his reign.
We give a date of had a 72,
the so called Temple of divine Claudius or at as as it is often referred to the
Claudine,
um,
uh,
in Rome and you see again the location of that Claudia,
a numb right here.
Now all that survives of this building today is its platform and I'm going to
show you some details of that platform in a moment of a tall great platform like
the platforms of the,
that we looked at earlier this semester upon which the temple rested.
All that survives is,
is that is part of that platform.
And what I show you first here is a restored view,
uh,
that comes from the Ward Perkins Textbook where you can get a very good sense of
what this platform look like.
It was a two storied platform as I think you can see very well.
It had barrel vaulted chambers,
it was made out of concrete barrel vaulted chambers made out of concrete.
And then on the front there were doorways at the bottom and windows on the
second tier.
And the facing the concrete,
the facing for the concrete was travertine cut stone travertine,
which should immediately ring a bell because you'll remember that it was cut
stone travertine that was also used for Claudius is harbor at Portas,
uh,
and also for the port of majority in Rome.
And you'll remember also the intriguing combination of,
of rust,
dicated masonry and smooth masonry for those to Claudia and buildings.
The same is true here.
So when Agra [inaudible] made a decision to put up a building honoring her
husband after his death,
a temple that would be to him as a deepest,
she turns back to the style that he himself seems to have favored this
combination of rustication and finished masonry to use for that building.
And I think this underscores the point that I made last time.
This choice of style a of this Russ dicated Mason restyle,
uh,
is not something that happened by happenstance.
It is likely because of Claudius,
his own predilection as a patron so that when add repeat decided how would be,
how it would be best to honor him.
Architecturally,
she wanted to honor him in the style that he himself liked.
Uh,
so she uses again,
this,
this combination of Rustic,
hated and finished masonry.
I can show you again,
uh,
some preserve sections of the,
of the podium of the temple of divine Claudius that will make this even clearer.
Uh,
before I do.
And you see it on the right hand side of the screen.
Just to remind you at the left of some of the great podia that we looked at
earlier this semester,
and since the exam is coming up,
there's no time like the present to see if you know your stuff because then he
can anyone identify this podium here on the left hand side of the screen?
Wendy
excellent.
The sanctuary of Jupiter anchor at terror Cina that's the podium.
And you'll remember what was characteristic of it is that it was made out of
concrete.
It was faced with opus and heritage.
It had travertine at the corners and over the arches and it had lateral arches
as well as others to allow the free flow of space.
So this idea of these great concrete podiums that served as the base for
sanctuaries.
It's the same idea here we see again,
a,
uh,
a podium that also has arches as you can see.
And then on the front of those arches,
in this case,
a great pilasters.
Uh,
and,
and if you look at those polarities very carefully,
and again,
it's done out of travertine in this case,
when you look at those,
those very carefully,
you see,
uh,
something very interesting here that makes these slightly different from the
other two that we saw.
Uh,
because you see,
you can see that the capital is finished.
You can see the upper part of the pilaster.
And then if you look very,
and then below that,
of course you see these ruts dicated blocks.
But if you look at the,
uh,
the,
at the,
in between each of those rustic,
hated blogs very carefully,
and I'll show you a better image in a moment where you can see this even more
clearly.
You will see that part of the pilaster emerges in between each of those rust
dicated blocks giving us even more.
The sense that that finished pilaster is somehow inside,
uh,
the,
is inside the rustic hated blocks waiting to emerge in a very interesting way.
We could,
we could psychoanalyze a Claudius we talked about his past and how he was not,
you know,
he was ignored as a child and he was shunted aside and because he stammered and
so on,
you know,
one could go very far and say that's Claudia's,
waiting inside to,
to,
to be,
to emerge sometime does it,
there's like a cocoon that allows the butterfly to emerge at some point later in
life.
Uh,
we could,
we could try that.
I don't know whether you would buy that,
but I mean,
it's one way in which one can think about this sort of thing.
But clearly,
whatever it meant,
if it was just to point to his antiquarian interest,
his interest in a more old fashioned stone construction at this particular
point,
uh,
it does seem to have something to do with the particular personality,
of this particular patron.
I,
here's another here's just comparing,
uh,
the,
the bay,
the podium of the Claudia and numb to the port majority in Rome.
Just to remind you of the rusty [inaudible] columns there,
the rust dicated drums of these engaged columns.
And then at the upper most part,
uh,
the way in which the upper part of the column and the Capitol are,
are dressed smooth,
uh,
and,
seemed to emerge.
And that's when I first made that point about the likelihood that the column
that we're supposed to read.
This is the column completed inside,
just waiting,
uh,
to,
to break free.
Uh,
and we see the same thing,
but a further elaboration of that here.
And I think you can see that much better in this particular detail where you can
again see the entire Pilaster,
uh,
behind the rest.
[inaudible] masonry.
Uh,
you see the,
the,
uh,
the finish capitol,
the finished and tablature up above,
and then you can make out the entire,
uh,
the entire pier all the way,
the polestar all the way down to the base and then super imposed or so it seems
it's not really super imposes just carved a in this way,
but in between those,
these rust dicated blocks,
again,
giving me at least the sense that the Polestar is done inside,
it's just waiting,
uh,
somehow for it's debut out of this travertine block.
Now what about the rest of the complex?
Uh,
we don't know exactly,
but we have some general sense that it is quite likely that it was similar to
the,
um,
the sanctuaries that we looked at earlier.
The sanctuary of Jupiter Ang,
sir at terror Cheena and Hercules at Tivoli.
And in fact,
we do have some fragments of this on what is called the Marble Plan of Rome.
I've referred to that before,
the so called Forma Orbis form,
Orbis for RMA,
a new word,U ,
R,
B I s the forma orbis,
which was a marble plan of Rome that was made in the early third century,
a,
uh,
which was housed in a building that I'm going to show you later today.
Uh,
and there are fragments of this structure there that give us a sense of what it
looked like.
And then in antiquity,
so we would have had the podium,
it's misread stored here.
You have to imagine the two tiers that we just looked at before,
not this sort of thing.
Uh,
but those beneath a serving as the podium or the decoration of the podium and
then above a large rectangular space with a temple pushed not quite to the edge
of the back wall,
but one of toward one of the walls dominating the space in front of it.
As you can see,
we don't know exactly what that temple looked like,
but it was probably a fairly conventional temple on the order of so many that
we've looked at this semester.
What's interesting about this,
it's different from the other sanctuaries that we saw is that in the rectangular
space above,
they seem to have planted a,
a lot of bushes as you can see here.
And that becomes very,
very popular way of decorating a these kinds of complex is in the Flavian
period.
We'll see another example later today,
the greatest,
the most famous,
uh,
building that was put up by Vespasian in the Flavian period was the so called
Colosseum,
uh,
which he began in the year 70 d so contemporaneous to the,
to the construction of the Claudia [inaudible].
Uh,
but it wasn't finished until after his death.
He died in [inaudible] 79.
He was emperor for nine years,
died of natural causes.
It wasn't completed until his son Titus became emperor and Titus completed it
and dedicated it.
In the year 80,
we see,
uh,
a view of the coliseum from above a Google earth image of the coliseum from
above.
It was a very large amphitheater that could hold 50,000 people.
It was made of concrete as we shall see.
And this aerial view is very helpful because it shows its relations,
shows its scale,
its size.
Uh,
it shows that in Rome today,
it serves as a kind of giant traffic circle.
As you can see here,
the Romans love the coliseum because it is an icon of their civilization,
but at the same time they hate it and they're always saying would,
would,
did it,
we could just get rid of it so the traffic would be smoother,
uh,
in this part of Rome.
And in fact,
there was a scheme a number of years ago now,
probably several decades ago by now,
there was,
um,
a Texan,
uh,
who,
who was actually interested in buying the coliseum and bringing it to Texas,
uh,
to display on his ranch.
Uh,
and,
uh,
fortunately,
I mean that Italy gave us some thought to that.
Uh,
but they decided obviously that they were not going to part with the coliseum.
And fortunately it has stayed intact and I don't think the Romans would have
been too happy about that at the end of the day,
despite the fact that they curse it out on a fairly regular basis.
But we see it here and it's useful view because it shows it in conjunction to so
many of the other buildings and complexes we've been talking about thus far.
This semester we're looking back from at toward the later arch of Constantine
that we'll look at at the very end of the course,
the Palatine hill in the upper left,
uh,
the Roman forum beginning over here with the temple of Venus and Roma that was
done in the second century.
We'll talk about that also later here.
The great via day Florian periodically,
uh,
designed at the behest of my Salini and on the right side of course,
the imperial fora with the forum of Julius Caesar and the Forum of Augustus,
uh,
that we have also looked at this semester.
Uh,
so here,
here you see it here and then I'm going to show you,
uh,
once again,
the site plan of Nero because it's important to know one of the most important
things to know about this monument is where it was cited and where it was cited
shows us again how incredibly shrewd Vespasian was when it came to establishing
a political agenda.
And when it came to trying to court the favor of the public,
uh,
he decided to raise,
and we,
I mentioned this before,
he raised to the ground Nero's Domus our area destroyed it,
destroyed it despite the fact that it had been done by these great architects,
despite the fact that it had,
was revolving ceilings,
would have been a really cool place for him to live himself.
Think about it.
Uh,
he and his dynasty,
uh,
but he decided to raise it to the ground for political reasons to discredit Nero
and,
and he hoped to gain favor with the populous.
And what he did smartly was to say,
what am I going to do with this property?
I'm going to return this property to the Roman people.
I'm going to build on it.
Something that they would really like to have.
So what he does is he fills in the artificial lake and he uses the area on which
the artificial lake was originally,
uh,
located to build the coliseum.
He puts the coliseum right on the location of the artificial lake.
And the message is clear.
What did the Roman people want?
More than anything else.
They wanted another,
and they wanted an amphitheater where they could go.
A large amphitheater were 50,000 of them could pack in and watch animal and
gladiatorial combat.
There is no better way to gain favor with the Roman populace.
And to build a building like this and to build it on top of Nero's pleasurable
artificial lake,
pleasurable only for himself was a huge coup on the part of this Bayesian.
And we see that happening here and right in proximity to the temple of divine
Claudius.
Notice the fact also that the,
the location of the Coliseum,
very close to the colossus,
the name of the Colosseum was really the Flavian amphitheater,
uh,
after the family name Flavius the Flavian amphitheater.
That's how it was known in antiquity,
but it has to be,
it came quickly to be known as the coliseum,
not because of its colossal scale,
which is what most people think,
but because of the colossus,
because of the statue,
uh,
of,
of Xena,
Doris that stood nearby.
And by the way,
the other thing that Vespasian did was to have the features of Nero raced on
that portrait and,
uh,
to make them into the more generic features of the sun.
God,
Saul himself.
So the statute continued to stand,
but it was fixed up.
Uh,
it was redone,
remade a so that it would look like Saul and not like neuro.
Uh,
but again,
the coliseum takes its name from that.
So if you are in any,
we used to have a coliseum here in new haven,
uh,
but it,
it,
if,
if you are in the future in any arenas that are called coliseums,
you'll know that that name,
it goes back to the Colossus of neuro colossus of Saul.
Uh,
not to the coliseum itself.
Ultimately,
although I think those who named those arenas,
we're obviously thinking about the Colosseum in Rome.
So the location of this,
of the coliseum,
extremely important and,
and a political statement on this patient's part and we see them,
this man,
this emperor of Rome Vespasian very cleverly using architecture to,
uh,
to,
further his own personal and political agenda.
This view also this plan cross section and a axonometric view that all come from
ward Perkins are also very helpful in us getting a sense of this building.
And I think you can see very quickly,
uh,
that like all other amphitheaters,
it had an oval or elliptical plan.
Uh,
it was built up with concrete,
a series of barrel and annular volts.
Uh,
and those,
that elliptical plan included essentially radiating a barrel vaults that barrel
vaulted ramps and passageways and a series of annular volted carters that
provide lateral circulation and that are a buttressed by the thrust of the
seating.
So it's a scheme that we know already from the amphitheater Pompei we know it
also particularly well from the theater of Marcellus enrollment.
Theater of Marcellus in Rome was just down the street practically.
I'll show you an aerial view later to show you its proximity to the coliseum.
It's not right next to it,
but it's within striking distance.
And uh,
it clearly the experiments,
the architectural experiments and the Augustan period at the theater of
Marcellus were very important in terms of this particular design.
It basically follows the same general scheme.
The major difference of course is that since the theater of Marcellus was a
theater,
it was semicircular and plan.
Whereas amphitheater architecture is always elliptical in plan and that is the
case also for the coliseum.
If we look at the,
I mentioned that there are annular vaulted Carter's,
we're looking at the card or on the first floor of the coliseum and you can see
very quickly that it is of course made of concrete.
How else would you get these annual or bolts that you see here?
They're very well preserved.
They're easy to study and you can see that those,
those uh,
annular vaults rest on great stone piers,
these stone piers made out of travertine.
Again,
you can see that,
uh,
extremely well in this particular view on the set.
That's the first floor on the second floor.
However,
we see something entirely innovative and that is the introduction of a new form
of vault that we haven't seen before.
Uh,
this is the so called groin or ripped vault,
uh,
spelled exactly as you think it would be.
G,
R o I n groin vault or the rib bald.
And you get when you,
when you take two barrel vaults and make them intersect the angles that you get,
create a this kind of groin vault.
And I show you a diagram here which makes that clear I think to you.
And then a view of the second story Carter is to show you these are actual groin
vaults,
these rib bolts that you see here,
which are very interesting and,
and add,
add something I think,
uh,
to these structures.
And they become very,
very popular after they begin to be used in the Flavian period.
They become very popular.
And we'll see,
uh,
the proliferation of growing vaults from this time on.
So we talked,
I talked at the beginning about what,
you know,
what,
what is concerned,
what is,
are the innovations of Nero's a domus salary a continued under the Flavian.
So we know that they,
the architects of Nero did not use groin vaults,
but they were very interested in the free flow of space.
And that interest in the free flow of space continues here as does
experimentation with concrete and we see it in the use of these groin vaults on
the second story of the Colosseum in Rome.
When you visit the Colosseum in Rome today,
you'll note that it does seem quite stripped bare unfortunately.
Uh,
but it's important for you to be aware of the fact that it too was highly
decorated as so many other Roman buildings.
And we do have engravings that were made grievings and paintings that were made,
uh,
when the coliseum was in better condition and when some of that stucco and
painted decorations still existed.
And I show you two drawings here that give you some sense of that and you can
see that all the surface was covered with stucco.
Uh,
and then with figural decoration,
all of which was painted both the,
uh,
the,
the vaults themselves,
as you can see above.
And,
uh,
the carters,
all of that,
a very elaborately decorated in ancient Roman times.
This is obviously an exterior view of the Colosseum in Rome.
The exterior of the building is actually quite well preserved.
And I think as you gaze at it,
and you certainly are struck by the similarity of the scheme to the scheme of
the theater of Marcellus in Rome.
Uh,
in this case,
the theater of Marcellus appears to have had three stories,
only two of which are currently preserved.
This had four stories,
four tiers,
as you can see here.
Uh,
again,
the structure itself is concrete.
The facing is travertine.
We see these great arches,
these great arcades just as we saw them in the theater of Marcellus.
And then also just like the scheme of the theater of Marcellus columns that are
placed in between those arches on the first three stories,
uh,
the columns in between those arches on the first three stories,
just as the theater of Marcellus have no structural purpose whatsoever.
They do not hold the building up as they would have in a Greek or a trust skin
context.
They are,
the building is held up by the barrel and the annular,
the barrel and annual or bolts that are made out of concrete.
Uh,
so these,
these columns have no structural purpose whatsoever,
and they are here essentially as the icing on the cake as ornamentation or
decoration,
but ornamentation or decoration that has certain meaning to it,
a meaning that certainly conjures up ancient Greece because you can see here
that they have used all the Greek orders,
the doric order,
the ionic order in the second story,
the Corinthian order.
All of these are engaged columns,
the Corinthian order in the third story.
And then in the fourth story we see they use pilasters.
These are Corinthian pilasters once again.
So doric ionic Corinthian Corinthian again at the upper most part columns that
have no structure that are used here as pure decoration,
but decoration that again has an ideological connection.
At the very top,
you can see the detail of the pilasters between them.
You see some travertine who's me blocks,
uh,
that are,
brackets it stick out on.
Those were to support the wooden poles that you'll remember from our
conversation about the amphitheater at Pompei,
uh,
supported the awning that was used,
when,
uh,
there was rain.
Two more views of the exterior of the coliseum,
little bit closer up where you can see very well here the doric order in the
first story travertine facing the ionic order in the second story.
And then the Corinthian engaged columns here and the Corinthian pilasters.
Uh,
and then also the brackets extremely well preserved on the Pantheon,
the Colosseum in Rome.
The interior is a different story entirely.
It is not as well preserved as the exterior.
It is fascinating however to see.
And I think you can tell from this particular view of the interior where we have
so far.
So as always we have so many tourists,
uh,
inside the Colosseum.
Uh,
I think they are very useful because they give you a very good sense of scale of
how truly enormous,
uh,
this building is a,
they also show you that much of what was once there is no longer there in the
interior of the structure.
As we look down on it,
we can see the elliptical shape of the arena.
We can see the substructures here,
all native concrete.
The ones that are below the arena itself were used for the storage of props,
uh,
but also for the housing of the animals that were brought up for animal combat.
There were small k,
there were small and larger cages down here.
And I'm going to show you what those look like in a moment.
Uh,
so that's the location of those,
but again,
not in very good condition today.
Uh,
even more striking is the fact that although you can see again,
the,
uh,
the concrete substructures for this,
the seats on which the Kavya rested.
If you look very carefully,
you will see there's only a single coonass,
uh,
that is still preserved with a small number of marble,
a marble seats.
The whole thing was she then marble in antiquity,
all of the seats would have been marble.
Uh,
only that small section is preserved.
And I can show you another view where we see the same here.
We're looking at that one.
A KUNAE is over here with that one set of marble seats,
the only marble seats that are still preserved in the Colosseum today.
Why is that?
You ask yourselves and you might ask me.
Uh,
the reason for that is that the coliseum was used as a marble quarry,
uh,
for,
for practically from the time,
uh,
you know,
I mean not,
not too long after it was built,
but certainly in the post end t period,
it was used very significantly as a marble quarry by whom?
By the great princes.
And even by the pope's,
the popes did not hesitate to plunge the Coliseum for the marble that they
needed for the buildings that they were putting up around Rome at the Colosseum
ended up in some extraordinary building.
So it was not for naught,
but at the same time,
obviously it,
it changed the face of the interior of the,
of the Colosseum forever as we can see.
So well here,
two models of what the substructures would have looked like in the area of the
coliseum where the animals were kept.
Uh,
and they had a system of ramps,
uh,
and pulleys that then they took the animals up,
either up the ramps or by Pulley,
uh,
from these cages.
You can see they had a metal grills in front of them.
Animals with diverse animals kept uh,
down here below and then brought up,
uh,
when needed through openings in the,
in the flow,
the pavement of the arena.
The arena would have been paved with concrete.
We have other examples of that elsewhere.
I'm going to show you one today.
Uh,
and there would have been holes in that,
uh,
by which you could bring the animals up to the arena.
This is a restored view of what the Coliseum would have.
The interior of the Colosseum would have looked like in antiquity.
Uh,
when a performance,
it was,
uh,
when I,
the gladiatorial performance was taking place,
we see that what they did was they covered over the arena with some kind of
ancient version of astro turf.
Uh,
they planted,
they put trees that fake probably,
I dunno,
real or fake trees,
not sure which,
uh,
props that were,
that took the shape of,
of mountains as you can see here.
And then the gladiatorial combat or the animal combat would take place against
that backdrop.
You can also see the street of the seats,
the wet,
the coffee of the wedge shape sections of those seats,
the Kootenay,
uh,
the 50,000 people packed in a for this special event.
And then,
uh,
at the upper most part you see the awning or this particular artist's rendition
of the awning.
I think it's very amusing that the artist is rendered it like an Oculus,
which is pretty unlikely that it looked quite like that,
but I guess that's a very Roman thing to do.
So he did that.
Uh,
but it looks,
it looked probably an antiquity quite a bit more like the awning that we saw in
the painting in palm pay,
uh,
that represented a characteristic awning for a Roman amphitheater.
The Coliseum,
extremely famous and its own day continued to be famous in antiquity.
I show you here a coin,
the reverse of a coin of a boy,
emperor by the name of Gordian the third you see Gordian up there,
uh,
the reverse of his coin and the third and the early Third Century d showing the
coliseums.
So we certainly know from that,
that it was still in good condition and being used in the third century,
we see the outside with it's tears of columns.
We see something,
an event going on inside.
We see people in the seats and we see those polls that supported the on in here.
And most interestingly,
we see the colossus,
which was clearly still standing also in the third century,
Aad,
the Colossus,
uh,
in which the features had been changed from those of Nero to those of Saul.
Uh,
with the raid crown.
it was very easy to do that because as I had mentioned,
neuro had been shown originally himself as saw with the raid crown.
So all they had to do was change the features of the face.
They could leave the crown in that crown,
clearly still a,
it's still there in the third century,
a,
but just again as a reminder that the coliseum gets its name from that colossal
statue that stood next door.
And this one last view of the Colosseum.
Uh,
this is a model which you have on your monument list,
a model that probably gives you as good an idea as any of what the exterior of
the building looked like in antiquity.
And I use it here to show you two things.
One that we do believe on the second and third stories.
There were statues,
statues placed in the niches beneath the arches.
And this also shows you very well the way in which the wooden poles rested on
the brackets,
those wooden poles to serve,
to support,
uh,
the awning of the structure,
anything and everything goes on at the coliseum.
When I started going to the coliseum more years ago than I want to say,
uh,
the Colosseum was very easy to get into.
Popped over there.
You could walk in and was in a flash,
never a problem.
It's become one of the greatest tourist sites in Rome.
And in fact,
a warning if you're going to be making your way,
I don't think,
at least one of you mentioned to me spring break trip.
Uh,
but if you're going to be making your way to the coliseum anytime soon or in the
future,
it's actually not a bad idea to go on light.
You can now go online and you can get tickets online for places like the college
and you don't need it for most places.
But for the Vatican,
the Colosseum,
the most popular,
it's not a bad idea to get tickets in advance because then you can go on the
short line instead of the line that you're going to have to wait for hours to
get in.
But while you're outside,
there's always something going on.
There's also never used to happen.
But recently,
uh,
the,
the Romans have gotten smart about,
um,
about realizing that everyone wants a photo op.
And so they supply a host of gladiators outside of the entrance way.
And especially since everyone is online for so many hours a,
you might as well have something to do.
So they,
they stock,
uh,
the stock,
the place with,
with modern gladiators who were more than willing for a certain number of
euro's,
uh,
to pose in your pictures.
And you see a young woman here taking her boyfriend or husband,
would whomever,
a picture of him playing the gladiatorial role with this sword.
As you can see,
I know lots of fun.
It's fun just to stand there and watch everybody posing for these extraordinary
pictures.
We saw that in the coliseum,
the substructures were very poorly preserved.
And so I wanted to show you another amphitheater where they are well preserved
so you can get a better sense of what those substructures would have looked like
in antiquity.
And so I take us back to back south.
We go down south to Campania once again to a place called pot swollen and pot
swollen is very near to buyer a and near to Naples and near to Pompeii and
Herculaneum and so on.
Uh,
a town that has one of the best preserved Roman amphitheaters in the,
from the ancient Roman world.
It dates to the late first century a d a,
and I show you a view here of the substructures of the amphitheater,
the Roman amphitheater at putts Wally.
And you can see what I mean.
Uh,
the annual or vaulted Carter's down below WellPreserved as are the,
uh,
the uh,
the,
um,
cages in which the animals were kept in antiquity.
The,
the gate,
the greats are gone.
But,
uh,
the,
the cages are still there as,
as much of the ceiling and it's actually a fun place to wander through because
the light effects are incredible.
The light effects through the openings in that ceiling that we're,
the openings through which the animals were,
uh,
were transported by ramp or by pulley up to the arena.
Here's another view where you can also get a great sense of these sub structures
of the places where the animals were kept,
uh,
and also have those openings in the ceiling that allowed them to be brought up
above.
And you can also notice very well here the fact that the construction in this
case late for century Aad is concrete faced with brick faced with brick.
And we talked about another important part of Nero's architectural revolution,
uh,
was the fact that they began to build buildings that were a brick faced concrete
buildings.
We talked about the fact that that had to do with the fire and the decision
taken that brick was more fireproof than stone and they began to use it and we
see it being used here.
So another important architectural rebel,
another important facet of Nero's architectural revolution that was not lost
with the emperor's death.
And here you can see the very well preserved a pavement of the arena done in
concrete with these openings in it at the same openings that you saw just before
from down below,
which the light came.
These are the openings through which props animals,
some of them are very small,
some of them are larger,
would allow,
uh,
individually some things to be brought up through them.
But you can also see there was a big open area in the center that was also used,
covered over,
uh,
when there was an event.
But,
uh,
that was also there in order to allow a freer flow and,
and allow the attendance to bring the animals up to the top.
So again,
a very well preserved pavement of the arena.
And you can also see in this view that the seats,
the Kavya of the theater at Putts,
Wally also extremely well preserved.
You can't tell here,
uh,
but the division into Kunae the same.
So we look to this amphitheater to give us a better sense of what the interior
of the Colosseum would have looked like in ancient Roman times.
We talked about the,
uh,
temple of divine Claudius.
I remind you of a model of it here again,
and the relationship of that temple of divine Claudius with the temple
conventional temple on top of a very tall podium.
The fact that that looked back to the architectural experiments very early on,
second for centuries BC at the sanctuaries of Jupiter anx or at Terra Cina,
uh,
and of Hercules,
victor at Tivoli.
Uh,
it was that kind of thing that was being looked back to.
And it's interesting to see that it was that same plan,
that idea of a great open rectangular space with a temple as part of it,
uh,
that was used and what the temple put along one of the longer ends that was used
by Vespasian,
uh,
for his own forum in Rome,
the so called forum pacas.
It's sometimes referred to as the Templem pacas because we're not actually sure
how it was used.
We don't think it was actually used as a typical forum with shops and,
and a law court and so on,
but may have been used in a different way,
and I'll speak to that in a moment so we don't quite know what to call it and we
call it either the forum park is or the temple and pockets in order to see its
location.
I show you this,
a view of all of the imperial fora in Rome,
those fora that line,
the via in the him periodically across from the Roman forum.
We've already looked at,
here's the tail end of,
or a side,
the side of the Roman forum here and right next to it too for that we've already
discussed the forum of Julius Caesar and then the forum of Augustus.
Nothing else.
This wasn't there then.
This wasn't there then,
but Vespasian decides to build a,
a forum himself in close proximity to the forum of Augustus.
In fact,
it's interesting to see that it faces the temple is actually on this end.
Uh,
so in a sense it faces the forum of Augustus.
So another smart strategic move on the part of smart political move on the part
of Vespasian to associate himself,
not just with Claudius,
good emperor who was divinized but also with Augustus,
the founder of the Julio,
Claudia and dynasty and the first emperor of Rome.
Uh,
so to build his,
his structure facing that of Augustus.
This is temple facing that of Augustus is a,
but you can see that he wants to outdo Augustus.
So he makes his larger than Augustus is,
uh,
this area here that's labeled as the forum of Nerva wasn't a forum at all at
this point.
It was a street called the argillite item,
m a,
and that street,
the Rj latum and you can see it labeled up there.
That street led into a part of Rome,
a residential area of Rome that I preferred to before called the Sabura Suv.
You are Aa.
The subura was again a place where they were a lot of of of,
I've mentioned it again,
we saw there a lot of,
or there were there a lot of apartment houses,
mostly made out of wood rickety apartment houses that were lived in by large
number of people with lesser means.
I and there were consequently always fires there and you'll remember that
Augustus is architects had to build that large precinct wall at a pepper reno to
protect the temple of Marzel.
Tore from the fires that used to break out all the time and this Bora.
So you have to imagine this is a,
as a street in between the forum of Augustus and uh,
Vespasian forum pockets in ancient Roman Times.
Also.
Interesting is again,
the plan,
a rectangle with the temple on one end,
a dominating the space in front of it.
Uh,
you can see that there are columns all the way around.
There are,
uh,
these,
um,
a these
alcoves that opened off the center space and you can see their screen,
uh,
from that center space also by columns.
Uh,
we know that,
uh,
some exotic materials were used to your marble that was brought from other parts
of the world.
We saw that beginning already under Nero bringing marble from Asia minor and uh,
and Africa and Egypt and so on for his buildings.
That also continues under the Flavian.
So another,
uh,
neronian innovation that remains important.
Uh,
we see it here.
We see red granite columns used for the colonnade.
We see yellow columns from,
uh,
Africa used for the columns,
that screen of these alcoves from the larger space.
And then we see white marble,
uh,
for the rest.
So this combination of imported marbles used for the farm pacas in Rome,
the forum park is no longer survives.
You can't see any of it today.
We do know it's location though.
And we do have a good sense of its plan once again from the so called Forma
Orbis from this marble map of Rome,
uh,
that has a few fragments of the,
of the Forum Forum Pacas you can see one fragment tier one fragment here and
then a third fragment up there.
Uh,
and those fragments are enough.
when we look at those,
study those and compare those to other buildings to allow a very accurate
reconstruction.
Uh,
it,
it tells us the shape of the temple and it shows us without any question because
one of the fragments includes lots of this,
that this too,
like the cloud.
He ate them in Rome,
had a bushes,
had bushes in as a,
you know,
a kind of garden,
uh,
the decorated the center of the structure.
So bringing,
uh,
the country in a sense,
into the city,
uh,
for these incredible complexes.
This is a restored view when you see it also on your monument list of what the
forum pacas would have looked like in antiquity,
a quite severe facade as it seems,
uh,
with a number of entrance ways.
The temple pushed up,
in fact,
not only pushed up against the back wall,
but part of the colonnade that flying sit on either side.
You can see the red granite columns.
You can,
you can't see the yellow columns that,
that would have been further in a screening.
She alcoves from the colonnade.
You see a,
an altar right in front of the temple.
You see the bushes that were part of the plantings that made this look like a
kind of garden,
a complex in front of the temple.
We don't actually know if it was used as a temple.
We have no of divinity that's been associated with it.
Uh,
we actually think it may have been used as a museum,
as a museum.
And I'm going to say more about that in a moment.
Here's another reconstruction.
This one is from Ward Perkins.
You can see that it is roughly the same as it is,
the same as the other with one exception.
And that is,
it shows an entrance way that it's made up of three doors.
And I'm a number of columns.
This was thought for a very long time,
uh,
to be the,
the,
the case that there was a,
uh,
an elaborate entrance way with columns and projecting and tablatures the sort of
thing that we haven't seen yet in built architecture.
But we did see in second style Roman wall painting,
but that idea has been discredited and now people believe it is much more likely
that the facade was very plain.
The reason that this idea came to the fore is that eventually when the argillite
item was filled in with a forum by Titus is seconds by Vespasian second son
demission.
Uh,
demission did build a forum that is in part preserved in which we will look at
next week,
I believe.
Uh,
but that forum had on the walls a series of columns with projecting and
tablatures.
So,
and that does still exist now.
We're,
part of it does still exist.
So I think that's what originally gave,
uh,
archeologists,
the idea that that was there before,
uh,
and was part of Vespasian is complex,
but that seems not to have been the case.
And you,
the reconstruction that you have on your monument list is the one that you
should go by.
Let's get back to the whole point about the museum.
Whether this served as a kind of museum in the time of the Flavian emperors,
I mentioned the great victory that Titus had over Jerusalem.
A victory,
at least from the Roman point of view,
was great.
Obviously it was not great for Judea because the,
uh,
the area was taken over by the Romans and the famous Jewish temple was
destroyed.
And a Titus also did not hesitate to a ramble through the,
uh,
with his men were the soldiers go through the temple and pick and choose what he
wanted to bring back to Rome as spoils.
He took the great seven branched candelabra them from the temple.
He took the Ark of the covenant from the Temple.
He took a whole host of other items from the temple and he brought them back to
Rome as trophies.
And we see this famous scene on the arch of Titus and arch that demission put up
in honor of his brother.
And we'll look at that on Tuesday.
The arch of Titus has a scene that depicts the Roman soldiers bringing the seven
branch candle,
labrum and a table with other objects on it from that temple back to Rome and
parading with those through an arch.
Uh,
those spoils we know were placed by Vespasian by his father with whom he shared
a joint triumph,
a because of this victory over Jerusalem.
It was placed in the forum pacas once that was built.
So it wasn't part of a place where he could display the spoils of war because of
the fact that the legitimacy that he gained,
uh,
through this conquest,
was so important to his dynasty,
to the right of his dynasty to rule and to the right of his sons to rule after
him.
So he wants to make that point clear.
But again,
he's very shrewd politically,
and he also wants to make sure that the people have access to this.
He,
he wants to remind them.
When Nero was emperor of Rome,
he had,
uh,
things in his villa that he would never have dreamed of sharing with you.
You weren't able to come in and dine there and have pedals and fragrances fall
on you while you dined.
Uh,
you were,
you were not allowed into this space,
but now you can come to the coliseum and you can go to this museum and while
you're in the museum,
you made it might as well look at these great spoils that I captured from
Jerusalem that bring credit to me and legitimacy to my dynasty.
He also took what's also interesting and makes this more museum like a,
is that he also took some of the statuary that Nero had stolen from Greece when
he went there to compete in those Olympic Games.
And so on that he had stolen from Greece and elsewhere,
uh,
and put it up in his villa.
He also put those in the museum and opened that collection also to the Roman
people.
And we even know some of the statues that were there that were taken from Nero's
stomas area and put into this museum.
One of them was a famous,
um,
cow,
a cow that had been done by the well known Greek artists.
Mirin and why Ron?
The cow of Myron.
Uh,
and the second was a,
a,
uh,
an image,
a sculpted image.
We're not sure.
I don't think we know whether it was in marble or bronze,
the original,
uh,
but an image of a reclining,
Nile River who is surrounded by 16 kids were running around,
up and down on top of him and around him.
Another famous statue that was in neuros possession that gets put into what
appears to have been a very important museum.
You see here,
uh,
another Google,
an excellent Google earth view,
aerial view of part of the Roman forum.
The Colosseum of course is way over here and we can see the central part or part
of the central part of the forum.
We're looking back toward the Victor Emmanuel monument.
We're looking back toward the competence folio is redesigned by Michelangelo,
the Oval Piatsa.
And in fact,
here we can even see in the upper left the theater of Marcellus.
So you can see that the theater of Marcellus was basically in a diagonal
diagonal dialogue in a sense with the,
uh,
with the coliseum that was located back over here.
The reason that I show this view to you now is to point out also the Tabula
Arrium,
which we've already looked at the archives.
It's on the back of the Senate Senatorial Palace,
redesigned by Michelangelo A,
but right in front of it,
there was a temple that was put up in honor of Vespasian by at his death by his
son,
Titus.
And then when Titus died,
only a few years later,
also of natural causes,
uh,
his brother Domitian became emperor and demission decided to rededicate the
temple to both of them,
to Titus,
uh,
to a Vespasian and also to Titus.
So it became the temple of the two DB D we,
uh,
because Titus was also divinized at his death and there were statue bases that
were found,
uh,
that stood in front of this temple with inscriptions indicating that they
honored those two individuals and that they were depicted undoubtedly and
statues in front of this temple.
Only,
uh,
three columns of that temple still survived some of the foundations as well.
Of course.
And you can see it in the Roman forum,
uh,
right near the top.
You,
him in Rome.
If you look at it,
you can see that these are Corinthian fluted capital's,
uh,
it was probably a quite conventional temple.
Uh,
but you do see that there is a freeze that seems to represent a number of
sacrificial implements,
a,
uh,
a libation dish and a picture and so on and so forth.
A very large chunk of that freeze and end tablature is still preserved today.
It's not with the temple,
but rather in the tabular IOM itself.
Uh,
and I show it to you here.
I'm extremely well preserved section of the decorative frieze of the temple of
Vespasian,
the Temple of Divine Vespasian in Rome,
which you see again dates to around 79 to 81 a d.
And it's very instructive not only in terms of the way in which,
uh,
tightest first and then his brother.
We're thinking of honoring members of their family,
uh,
but also in the,
in the,
uh,
um,
incredible in how ornamental this is.
I mean that this is,
this is decoration that is more richly textured than any that we've seen thus
far and also more richly undercut.
The artists are beginning to use the drill,
uh,
to create very deep shadows,
among the decorative motifs to make them stand out even more.
And you might remember,
I didn't bring it back to show you,
but you might remember that section that showed you from the forum from the
temple of Venus,
Ghana treks in the forum of Julius Caesar where I mentioned that that had been
restored in the time of demission second son of Vespasian and also in the tray
Janick period.
And that the,
the very deep carving indicated to us that deep carving indicated too is not
only that it had been done later,
uh,
but also the fact that the flavor ones,
we're particularly interested in this very ornamental decoration,
very deeply undercut ornamentation.
And we see that so well here we see also the interest in the variety of motifs,
uh,
in this freeze.
Uh,
and,
and the decorative part of it.
And then the frees itself is very interesting.
If we look at the objects,
we see that they are mainly objects that are used in ritual sacrifice.
Uh,
we see the skulls of bulls just as we saw them in the inner precinct of the Arra
pop.
This one on either side,
we see a libation dish,
we see an ax over here.
Uh,
that's to knock out the animals.
Here's the a,
the knife to slit the throat of the animals,
the pitcher to pour wine on an altar,
a whip for whatever purpose that had.
Uh,
and then over here a helmet.
As you can see.
So all of these implements that were used in a sacrifice regularly used in
sacrifice,
arranged like a still life against a blank background.
And I dunno about you,
but when I look at this,
I am reminded of some of fourth style,
a Roman wall decoration of the still life paintings that we saw on the third and
the fourth style where you have individual objects against a blank background.
Uh,
and also also the,
the decorative nature of this conjures up some of the decoration that we see,
the perfusion,
the almost overly decorative element of fourth style Roman wall painting.
And since this dates to 79 to 81,
and you'll remember the fourth style,
uh,
is 62 to 79 at pom pay.
But we know that the Ford style continued on.
It was the fourth style that was the most popular style post 79,
obviously not in pom pay but it or Herculaneum but elsewhere in the Roman world.
So this very much in keeping,
we're seeing an architecture,
something very much in keeping visa vi decoration as we see in fourth style
Roman wall painting.
The last monument that I want to show you today is in many respects the most
important.
That seems like a strange thing to say because what could be more important than
the icon of Rome?
The Coliseum.
But when we think about it,
the Colosseum was actually a fairly conservative building,
right?
I mean it goes back to the uh,
the,
the amphitheater,
it Pompei and its general plan and it is quite similar to,
in fact very similar to the theater of Marcellus,
which was done at the time of Augustus.
And Augustus was trying to connect his reign to that appears equally in Athens
and was using stone construction and the coliseum is up stone construction,
although it also of course makes use of,
uh,
of,
of annual annular vaults out of concrete,
uh,
and also integrates with the new groin vaults.
But for,
for,
for all intents and purposes,
a relatively conservative building at this time,
the Colosseum was the building that I'm now going to show you.
It was not that way at all.
Uh,
even though it's a building that is much less well known than the coliseum,
and it also doesn't exist any longer unfortunately.
And that,
and those are the baths of Titus,
a very important structure for us.
The Bas of Titus,
the tear,
my tt,
the bads of Titus,
uh,
that date to Adhd,
right smack in the middle of Titus is brief reign of 79 to 81.
Uh,
they,
uh,
were put up in Rome and they were put up in Rome.
Not surprisingly,
you know,
the punt,
you know the narrative here,
not surprisingly on that land that had earlier been expropriated by Nero,
another instance of the Flavian emperors giving back to the people.
You've given them a museum that you've given them a,
an amphitheater and now you're going to give them a bath next to an
amphitheater.
The bath is what they wanted most of all place where they could go to bay but
also hang out with their family and friends.
Uh,
so again,
giving back to the people what they wanted.
Wise,
shrewd political move on the part of Vespasian being followed by his equally
shrewd son Titus.
The location of the bows of Titus was next to actually what you see here on top
of the Golden House is actually the plan of a later bath.
The Bas of the emperor Trajan,
which we'll look at in the future.
But the smaller bags of Titus were put to the,
um,
I believe it was,
yeah,
the west of the,
uh,
eschalon wing of the Golden House.
Right,
right.
Just between the bolden house and where you see eschalon written up.
There was the location of the bads of Titus.
All that survives or the bads of Titus is what part of one wall,
a brick faced concrete wall with some engaged columns.
That's all we have.
But the building was still standing at two.
The building was still much better preserved in the 16th century when it was
drawn by a renaissance architects.
Uh,
most specifically by Andrea Palladio,
his name I put on the monument lists for you,
Andrea Palladio drew a very complete plan of it and it is on the basis of that
plan that modern,
uh,
plans are made of the bads of Titus.
And I show it to you here and we believe this is a very accurate plan of the
baths of Titus.
And I compare it to you for you here with again,
those of you studying for the midterm.
What's this?
The stay be bad.
Stop being Baz in palm pay,
second century BC.
Very good.
Uh,
and we talked about that as a typical,
the typical earlier,
a bad structure and just a very quick review to remind ourselves of its major
features.
Uh,
it had the polestar over here surrounded by columns on three sides,
the PC now,
or the Natacha swimming pool at the left.
And then most importantly,
the bathing block on the right side of the structure amend section and a women's
section with that sequence of rooms.
The uh,
the,
uh,
the Apo d Terrian where the dressing room,
the tip Darian rectangular or the warm room,
the caldarium hot room with a,
an apps and a cold water splash pool as Cold War's splash basin.
And then most importantly,
the frigate Darian that small round a building with radiating alcoves.
That was the typical Roman bath structure until we begin to see,
or our first example in Rome of the so called imperial bath structure,
uh,
the,
the plan that is used by the emperors for the bass that they build in Rome,
it is possible that Tituss was not the first,
there's been some speculation.
We know that Nero had built a bath.
There has been some speculation that narrows bath may have been the first
example of the imperial plan,
but we don't know for sure,
but Tituss of the ones that we know have the specifics about,
we know that Tituss was definitely an example of this imperial best structure
and the features that are outstanding here that we need to focus on or the fact
that this imperial best structure had a very elaborate entrance way,
uh,
that consisted either of columns on square basis or peers in the front.
Uh,
there seemed to have been a series of groin vaults.
Anytime you see an x in plan,
that means a growing vault,
a,
an elaborate stairway,
some more columns or peers here,
uh,
and,
and more groin vaults and another stairway leading into a double polestar in a
sense,
or you could call it a combined Balestra here on the southern side.
And then most,
and that you can see the sister and on the outside of the precinct who can see
the cistern that fed water into this best structure.
It's roughly rectangular as you can see.
And unlike the stop being bas at palm pay,
where you have the bath complex on the right side,
you can see that the bath,
the rooms of bath,
the bath,
the rooms that are used for bathing are at the center of the plan.
Uh,
which makes sense from,
from the Roman standpoint.
You know,
the Romans thought,
you know,
we're very,
uh,
focused on axiology and symmetry and that's exactly what they've done here.
They've placed the bathing block in the center.
They've lined the rooms up,
it axially with one another.
They've placed rooms on either side,
symmetrical rooms.
It's the same on the left as it is on the right.
Uh,
submit rooms are symmetrically disposed around that central bathing block and
they've taken the frigging Doriam which was the smallest,
albeit the most interesting architectural,
but the smallest room in the bath.
And they've made it the largest room in the bath because you can see it f a very
large cross shaped room within apps on one end,
a groin vault over the center,
a single large groin vault over the center,
flanked by and buttressed by two barrel bolts,
one on either side and then opening off those barrel vaults,
a series of rectangular,
uh,
alcoves with as you can see with walls that are scalloped.
Uh,
and then with columns that screen,
uh,
those alcoves from the central groin vaulted space.
So an entirely different way of thinking about the frigging Darian.
Then that into the tip of Darian from the Frig,
adore him again through a screen of columns.
That's Rick that's fairly conventional,
rectangular and then into,
we see here double called Aria to call Daria.
They also in a kind of cross shape,
although a cross shape that if he was a little bit more rounded than the case of
the frigate Darian,
they to screened by columns on three sides,
very open,
allowing a free flow of space in a way that was not true of the palm pay.
And Bas with the inference was with Vic tiny from one room to another here a
gate,
a great deal of emphasis on the free flow of space.
So what's most,
what's very important here,
the way I want to end today is essentially where I began,
what innovations of Nero's architecture lived on despite has done not to a
memoria.
And despite the fact that his buildings were destroyed,
his building's no longer stood.
The Dome is salary and no longer stood to be studied.
Uh,
and yet,
uh,
what we see is some of,
of the innovations did live on and the ones that did a include,
and let me just compare as the last image compare,
uh,
the octagonal room and axonometric view of the octagonal room,
with the bas of Titus in Rome.
What we,
what we see are some of the experimentations that were taking place in private
architecture,
palace architecture.
And I,
and I should make the point that just as we've said that to market texture was
often very eccentric and very experimental.
The same was true for private architecture.
Not surprisingly,
these are buildings that people make personal decisions about how do I want to
live and what kind of spaces do I want to live,
uh,
and in Wa and where do I,
and what kind of building do I want to be buried?
That's it.
Those are very personal decisions and they were much more likely to be
experimental decisions where public architecture had to toe the line to a
certain extent and had to be more closely aligned with what had gone before.
And it was also more referential in terms of looking back to other emperors and
so on.
So we see experiments and private,
uh,
palace and to market texture,
villa architecture that we don't tend to see as much in public architecture.
But what we see happening here is act is very momentous.
And that is the lessons that were explored first in private architecture are
being adopted in the most public of all Roman buildings,
a bath building.
And it's being done in a very different way from the coliseum.
Most important,
the most important adoptions innovations that we're in.
Nero's Domus area that are also included in the bads of Titus are axiology
symmetry.
And I've described both of those already knew vaulted shapes,
which we also did see in the coliseum,
the use of the groin vault extensively here.
And then perhaps most importantly,
this free flow of space,
the free flow of space,
the vistas,
the panoramas from one part of this bath structure to another that is very
different from the bath structure of the past on the bass structure of
structures,
for example,
of palm pay.
So what we see in some is the fact that despite Nero's Dom Natya Memoria,
I,
despite the fact that that allowed,
uh,
authorities,
and in fact the,
the new emperor to destroy the portraits of Nero,
to raise his palace to the ground,
which Vespasian did after all,
despite that,
the,
uh,
the architectural innovations of Nero's Domus Aurelia lived on,
they lived on in the bas of Titus.
And we're going to see they lived on in perpetuity,
and we're going to see them continuing to have a huge impact on the evolution of
Roman architecture.
Thank you.